In a world of conflicting values, it's going
to be difficult to develop values for artificial
intelligence that are not the lowest common
denominator.
In Asia particularly, we have a lot of countries
that believe that governments are the best
way to make decisions for people, and that
individual human rights can be voiced only
by the state.
In that context, if we are trying to come
up with artificial intelligence that recognizes
individual human rights, and that looks to
empower citizens and users, and to create
transparency, it's going to be really challenging
to come up with an international-coordinated
regime that does this.
People have developed AI that is predictive,
people are researching ways to make sure that
AI is able to target advertisements at people
depending on their preferences, the devices
they use, the routes they take.
Now, that kind of predictive AI can very easily
be used for surveillance.
And it's a fact in Asia that the states in
Asia, including India, are investing very
heavily in mass surveillance and they are creating
large, centralized databases that they haven't
fully worked out how to sweep as of yet.
In India, we've also got news of the state
using drones to monitor assemblies of people
in public places to make sure that nothing
goes wrong.
We've got news that the government is developing
social media labs that are supposed to watch
the online social media to see what people
are saying and what kinds of subjects are
trending.
And in that context, again, the question we're
asking ourselves is when the state chooses
to use its resources to get AI to
do these things, how far is AI going to be
used to control and monitor the citizen, as
opposed to enabling the citizen?
Because in democracies like ours, the balance
of power between the citizen and the state
is really delicate.
And there is a great potential for AI to tip
that balance of power in favor of the state.
While it's important to make sure that we
don't chill innovation, it's also important
to be cautious, and to make sure that technology
doesn't drag us down a dark path.
We've got examples from history like the Manhattan
Project, like the way in which technology
was used during the Holocaust, to remind us
that if we're not careful about what we do
with technology, it can be abused in ways
that we will come to deeply regret.
So it's necessary to make sure not just that
we have human rights, political theory, but
also the other disciplines that understand
what it means to be human and how to engage
with humans involved in the designing of AI.
If we don't work out a way in which citizens
are able to ask the right questions about
AI to ensure accountability every time AI
is created and used, we might be heading towards
a world that Orwell predicted.
and that would be really unfortunate, because
new technology should lead to a better world,
and not a more controlled world or an unequal
world.
As you know, technology is easily sold to
people, and it moves very quickly around the
world, and so, it's really important to intervene
in Asia at the stage of design.
People sometimes have the best of intentions,
but because of the way in which they're educated
or they're taught to think, the way in which they design
technology can end up being really damaging to
the world.
Conversely, it could end up being really beautiful
as well, and that's why it's really important
that we get into AI right now and help the
people that are designing it to think of it
in a way that imagines a better world.